hey youtubers it's Charlie you guys may
have heard the WTF news Deathstroke is
now supposedly off-limits to the TV
shows meaning that a new Bennet could
not come back to arrow if he wanted to
both Stephen Amell and Manu Bennett
separately have talked about how they
want to do Deathstroke on the show again
Stephen Amell is like yeah I totally
want my new to come back he's an awesome
guy awesome character Minu is like yeah
I would totally love to come back he's
doing another show called shannara
chronicles' right now but they don't
shoot as many episodes as arrow so it's
a little easier for him to guest star on
other TV series arrows still plotting
out the last couple of episodes for this
season for season four
so naturally Marc Guggenheim who's
really good about answering questions on
his tumblr is like you know we can't
really do Deathstroke because he's
earmarked for another live-action
property now what does that mean mostly
it means these plugins show up in the
movies Suicide Squad might get a mention
I know a lot of people are wondering if
he's gonna be in that movie we don't
know for sure yet but I do think given
the fallout from the Teen Titans TV
series they're refocusing their efforts
on doing those characters in the movies
they're already doing cyborg cyborg is a
really easy in for Teen Titans
characters especially they're gonna be
doing cosmic stuff and they're gonna
have all these other films to fill out
with characters how would they use
Deathstroke in the movies though he's
mostly a Teen Titans villain and really
he's a larger DC assassin for hire but
that's his whole deal he shows up and he
always gets his man he's Deathstroke the
Terminator I know that the version they
did on arrow was Dee powered that's
because of the way the TV shows were
handling powers at that point we hadn't
really got Barry Allen yet we hadn't had
the Dark Matter explosion but by
comparison in the comics Deathstroke's
powers are off the charts and his sword
is magical he has an ABEO plate just
like katana has a magical blade it's not
the same type of magic but he has a
really powerful sword he's a lot more
intelligent than most of the other
characters and thus that gives him
better fighting ability he's able to
calculate every possible move that
you're going to make so a really good
example of him from what kind of a bad
story is identity crisis our third light
the original dr. light is worried that
the Justice League is going to take him
in and kick his ass so he hires
Deathstroke to protect him from the
Justice League in Deathstroke by himself
is able to hold off the entire Justice
League so I think when he shows up in
the movies we're gonna see a version
that's closer to that some
whose so good that they seem like they
have supernatural abilities even though
the movies are trying to be a little bit
more realistic like what if an alien
really did land on earth what would that
be like what if a Batman really did
exist the movies are taking a little
more practical approach but as we get
closer to Justice League it's getting a
little more fantastical technology's
getting crazy Lex Luthor is
experimenting with metahumans that's one
of the things I'm really excited about
in Batman V Superman is the idea that
Lex Luthor is obsessed with metahumans
so I think that's going to play into the
larger DC universe Batman V Superman is
really the launching platform for all
this there's a lot more magical
fantastical things going on you have
enchantress and Suicide Squad by the
time we get to that because of Batman V
Superman it'll seem a lot more plausible
in this universe but let me know in the
comments how do you want the movies to
use the Deathstroke character and do you
think that he's going to show up somehow
during Suicide Squad now there are a lot
of people that'll show up in Batman V
Superman that will be on a list they'll
be mentioned we won't see him a lot like
Aquaman is a very small part of Batman V
Superman although he is involved with it
so the first time we learn about
Deathstroke it might be in a really
offhanded way like someone might mention
him in passing and then we see him in a
really big way in a future film as far
as I know there's no official Teen
Titans movie on the books I don't know
what they would call it they wouldn't
call it Teen Titans need either call it
Titans or they just call it the cyborg
movie and they turned the cyborg movie
into a Teen Titans movie Geoff Johns did
do that special where he teased out the
other films like the Green Lantern's
film that's going to be coming there's
still a lot of stuff that's already been
planned that they're working on that
they just don't have any material to
show off they're still trying to figure
the scripts out they're still trying to
figure a concept art like they haven't
even cast anyone for the Green Lantern's
movie yet but that's so far off that we
really need to pay more attention to
what's going on in Suicide Squad really
the bummer here is that arrow loses one
more big comic book character than it
could have done an awesome story with I
was hoping they do Judas contract at
some point for the Teen Titans comic way
back during arrow season 2 when they
were doing the big Deathstroke arc they
teased out his son Joseph Wilson who is
Jericho from the comics they could have
done a Judas contract they're doing hive
this year hive is a big part of that the
Judas contract Ark involves tearing hive
down maybe arrow isn't ready to do that
yet because they just pulled that toy
off the shelf so they want to play with
a little bit but now with the loss of a
Amanda Waller Deadshot most of the
Suicide Squad characters is looking
pretty grim that's why I feel like
there's less Argus stuff going on or
more in a roundabout way like there's a
king shark episode of the flash coming
up it's gonna be a Diggle and Lyla
crossover
I think Lyla is gonna be running Argus
now just careful for spoilers for arrow
this season I have to talk about Amanda
Waller it seems like the movies did the
same thing with Deathstroke that it did
with Amanda Waller gonna be a really big
version of her in the movies played by
an award-winning actress so Warner
Brothers doesn't want a version of her
on TV just remember though the back door
is always gonna be the multiverse the
flash just tease that out careful for
spoilers from the flash for last night
if you haven't seen that yet but there
is an alternate version of a character
in The Suicide Squad who died on earth
one he shows up on earth two he's a
completely different person but it's the
same character so they could probably do
some of these characters using earth two
plots but for practical purposes I think
most earth two stories will be flash
based stories so if we see earth two
versions of Suicide Squad characters we
would probably only see them on the
flash in related news tonight Oliver and
Merlyn are going to wreck the [ __ ] out
of each other so be sure to watch it's
gonna be a lot of fun there's a new
round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
and I'll talk about the mystery Green
Arrow we saw on the flash last night
that's mostly a legends of tomorrow
thing but I'll talk about it during my
arrow video - for big words
holy [ __ ] connor hawke so white guys
wait for my arrow video to post tonight
you can click here for all my Suicide
Squad Batman V Superman videos and you
can click here for last night's episode
of the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight